we have right here to my left a man who
has the most let me get this right
career passing yards career pass
completions career completion percentage
no other individuals had more 300-yard
passing game for yard passing games
touchdown passes in a game consecutive
games with a touchdown past 5,000 yard
passing seasons I mean I could go on and
on but I'd like to talk to the man put
your hands together for Drew Brees how's
life that's it's going good good you
know I mean I I guess we could just get
straight into it here with do you feel
drew Brees that your team deserve to be
here
this week well listen we'll we'll go
ahead and talk about the call I've tried
to live my life weren't about the things
I can control right and then and then
try not to worry about the things I
don't control and unfortunately within
the game of football listen it's an it's
an imperfect game played by imperfect
people right yeah and so there's there's
throughout the course of a game and
there's there's mistakes made all over
the place right
yeah and it's it's unfortunate that a
game that meaningful that's significant
at that point in the game could have had
a different outcome had it been for you
know one one call right one one
officials call but again that's not
something that we control I think about
the things that happen before that and
after that that maybe were within our
control that might have allowed us to
have a different outcome and be playing
here in this Super Bowl but as I've had
time to you know get some closure and
then reflect on
I think our season man there's so much
to be proud of and I had so much fun
playing football this year with my team
I'm really excited about the future that
we have with a lot of our young players
and it certainly rejuvenated me and and
and and really made football a lot of
fun yeah I mean in terms of that no team
has ever had nine undrafted players
catch a touchdown pass in the same
season are you aware of that are you are
you aware of that yeah somebody told me
that after I guess it was after the game
we had two more undrafted free agents
catch touchdowns in that NFC
Championship game right I mean so what
was that like for you sometimes because
it was like what meeting nametags for me
sitting at home obviously you know these
guys you play with them you're
practicing with them what challenge did
that present for you drew
Miyoung guys a lot a lot of guys that
had to step into roles that maybe were
not anticipated you know prior to the
season but right but you know there
there are some of those household names
like Michael Thomas and Mark Ingram and
Alvin Kamara and then right as you as
you as this season kind of went on and
you know we lost Ted Ginn early for a
while and so all of a sudden you know
you had these young young receivers that
had to had to step up and fill pretty
significant roles for us and listen that
that's a challenge just because so much
of the passing game is timing and it's
trust and it's it's just that time on
task that you know you only have so much
that during the offseason and man the
more years that go by like for example
now going into year three with Michael
Thomas man I've got such a great
relationship and rapport with him and
trust and confidence level when we're on
the field and you know so just common
sense would tell you man it was a work
in progress at times just to just to be
able to to develop that you know as we
were on the move yeah
drew Brees here on the Rich Eisen show
so you said you've had some time to take
in between the NFC Championship game and
now did you do the time spent like your
coach said that he did Netflix in a
Netflix like screaming Netflix by the
way is what anything similar for that
for you obviously you've got younger
kids that's got some support it into my
kids you know I obviously it was it was
a shot first of all you know we didn't
anticipate that and there's there's just
that you know during the season you have
a tough loss and it's alright you know
you got to put it to bed within 24 hours
then it's on to the next opponent and
you begin looking forward to that and
and working towards that there's just
that finality right right of the end of
the season and especially the way in
which you know we lost in the
expectation level so listen that was
difficult you know you kind of run the
game over and over
your mind but typically what I do is I I
go to all those plays that I know could
have been difference makers and I just I
create a different outcome you know this
is when I encounter that situation in
the future this is the way we'll handle
it this is so you you almost you almost
make you make the place right you're
right you change the outcome and then
you're able to put it behind you and
move on I don't want it to linger you
know I mean listen it hurts it's things
probably a piece of it always will and
yet you just have to believe that
there's better things ahead and then
that we'll learn from this and we'll
become stronger because of it yeah I
know it's as you said the finale the
finality to it but it's kind of
remarkable but you know when it happened
you know I came on my show the next day
I said it was the worst non call I've
ever seen in any sport in any situation
and the only thing came close was you
know the 98 World Series would mark
Langston threw a ball right down the
middle of the plate to Tino Martinez and
it was called a ball and but Martinez
hit a grand slam home run on the next
pitch like that's the only thing I could
equate to it and I'm I was wondering
when everybody and the media fandom
would turn the page to the Superbowl and
we it's wrong it's the Friday before the
game and we we really haven't done it
yet it's still it still is there for
that is it any sort of aspect that's
been missing that you think needs to
happen for closure or some sort of
cauterization for you Saints fans or
what have you
well I think what what continued to
create the swell was the fact that
nothing was coming out of the league
office nothing was coming from the
Commissioner to address the situation
immediately after which I I I think we
all felt like that was a very obvious
solution or at least some sort of
response that just recognizes what
happened and acknowledges it and says
you know what man we need to work to
make sure that you know something like
this doesn't happen again obviously we
all recognize just like I said earlier
it's it's an imperfect game right right
and things happen fast and so you're not
going to make every call you're gonna
miss some calls and yet
you know for something that obvious to
happen and one just one penalties to
penalties on play that but we're both
you know III technically look miss but
but III think had it been acknowledged
immediately after I think that would
have allowed everybody to begin you know
being able to move past it or at least
say okay it's been it's been
acknowledged we've talked about it
they've talked about potential solutions
now we can move on with the Super Bowl
and then we can move on to what those
solutions potentially might be this
offseason with competition committee and
everything else and who knows how
that'll shake out but the fact is it
just lingered it was allowed to linger
and linger because there was no response
coming from from New York so the
response from New York just
acknowledgement of the elephant in the
room without I guess throwing all the
officials under the bus right I mean I
guess that might have been some sense it
I'm I'm just trying to walk through what
the sensitivity might have been and what
a statement just saying hey that that's
a call we wanted to have made which is
what the commissioner said in the press
conference this week just putting that
in a press release on Monday or Tuesday
or just saying that that would have been
sufficient you listen I think that's
common sense you know I mean I think
that's that's that's part of your job
that's your responsibility right I mean
just like it is a head coach or a
quarterback or somebody else to be able
to stand up after a really tough loss
just like this one and then talk about
it right and and and acknowledge certain
certain shortcomings that maybe you
weren't personally involved in in the
game right or whatever it might be you
got to stand up and you got to be able
to do that and take those bullets at
times and I just think it's unfortunate
that that Roger Goodell and I think just
the NFL in general did not address that
issue right right afterward I think
that's that's part of their
responsibility drew brees here on the
Rich Eisen show care of also Biofreeze
which we'll get to in a second so what
about the potential folding of judgment
calls in to instant replay the Players
Association which obviously you're an
integral part came out and said hey kind
of don't forget about us when you're
talking in the competition committee
about making potentially such a major
move on that front would you be cool
with folding
judgment calls into that which might
clue include offensive pass interference
might include a holding penalty on one
of your hard-working protectors up front
would you be cool with that
I think it's I think it's I think it'd
be really hard to do you know I think
you open it up a can of worms when you
start talking about reviewing penalties
if you did do that I think you'd have to
you'd have to relegate it to just a
certain number of penalties because you
could arguably call holding on every
play right in the NFL you know and that
goes for DB's wide receivers you know
the line both offense and defense right
I mean all over the place you try to
teach great technique you you you you
try to you know play that way and yet
you know there there are subtle things
that just they happen on every play
right so you've seen you've seen things
evolve with instant replay over the last
ten years right from from the
perspective of hey we're gonna review
turnovers right to okay now we're gonna
review every touchdown play okay to now
okay each coach gets you know to
challenge flags right oh but you're not
going to challenge within two minutes
that's gonna be reviewed in the booth
right that's going to New York and we're
gonna make sure that you know we're
eliminating we're trying to create a
mistake-free environment when it comes
to that but man when you start talking
about all penalties I mean that's I
don't know if that's realistic maybe
there's a solution with with with with
with a few of them but I'm not sure yeah
I'm just trying to come up with
something where what happened to your
team in your city it doesn't I think
that's what everybody I think that's
what everybody wants yes if we're
sitting at home I mean it was so damn
obvious again no it just it's just we
got to come up with something that
creates an ability to catch that that
one in particular you never know what
happens after that obviously you know
but so that's that's all I'm just hoping
the week that something could come up
with to catch that in the sieve of
replay yeah listen I'm with you I think
the you know I think that the another
discussion is you know officiating crews
they have their crew throughout the
season and then for the playoffs they
become all-star crews right right and so
you have crews that are made up of you
know members from a lot of different
crews that maybe haven't really worked
together in the past and so what is that
that rapport what is that level of
communication you know when it's just
like a team right yes you sit there and
it's that repetition repetition and so
you just work well together as a crew
because you've been doing it for the
last 17 weeks and in most cases these
guys have been on each other's crews for
years right but now you take an all-star
crew and it's kind of like the Pro Bowl
where you're playing with guys that
you've never played with you know and
and and there's a chemistry means
something and everything exactly right
yes so maybe maybe that's a fix that
comes from this just from the standpoint
that men these these crews or if you
keep them together they're gonna work
better together drew brees few more
minutes left with him here on the Rich
Eisen show so the other question you get
every year is how you feel in and what
what you want to do even though we're
now seeing Brady at age 40 and age 41
make back-to-back Super Bowls you
obviously coming so close and
back-to-back years to matriculate closer
to the game how are you feeling right
now and your thoughts on how much longer
you want to play I feel good you know my
body feels good my mind feels good I
mean I I think anytime after a hard
fought season you know you're you're
ready for a little break and you take
that time with with your family to
recharge the battery and and then begin
to develop a plan for you know the
things that you want to accomplish this
offseason to get yourself ready for a
championship season so I'm gonna take
that same approach a few tweaks in my
mind that I know I already want to make
that I think you're gonna improve things
so do you got can you know that's trade
secrets okay trade secrets you okay but
no I'm I'm you know I'll be excited once
that process starts but right now man
it's all about my family's 45 still
number I think it's possible I mean it's
it's certainly possible I believe that I
know Brady said that I've said that but
you know we'll see I'm just gonna take
it one year time really just trying to
enjoy the moment and it's also cool I
mean you mean that little boy that had
the headsets on his tenth mount right
now yeah yeah so and your kid your other
kids are how old how old are they so ten
eight six and four okay so they're
getting older so they can remember when
daddy was playing football that's
exactly right
so these are these are fun times so yeah
I mean you play a few more years than
the four-year-old could be 10 also just
throwing that out there
mm-hmm that's uh listen anything Foss
it's a goal it's certainly if you got my
Oh freeze on your side right that's
right what is this right what is by off
remember number-one topical pain
reliever
great for sore muscles great two for me
pre practice pregame just to get myself
you know warmed up ready to go yeah just
a great way to offset that and would
that be helpful for me running my 40
absolutely absolutely I would and I'd
probably I'd probably go I'd probably go
hamstrings quads calves yes definitely
like calves would have usually first
first thing to go
you know what does that mean that it's
like my last thing to go that's the
theme using the wrong muscles I don't
know that's that's not good okay because
you know you just turned 40 I'm about to
turn 50 really yeah and I'm doing this
tomorrow I'm rehearsing this should be
part of your daily your daily routine
well I might need some right now because
I'm running against Usain Bolt tomorrow
are you really yes what's the distance
it's a 40 at the NFL experience okay and
we've been talking throughout the show
today what yard line
will I be at right when he hits the four
it's Oh can I get to the 20 I thought I
thought I thought we were handicapping
this a little bit and maybe putting you
at the 10 the 12 the 15 the 18 I'd uh I
think we've been saying the over-under
on the show is like 17 and a half okay
so would you take the over or the under
I'm not where I could reach by the time
and you saying hits the 40 okay see I
was saying you you you get a head start
and then and then and then let's and
then let's hit the finish line at the
you know yeah yeah see III like that
better so now it's really the over/under
of he's 40 yeah I think 17 is good see I
think yeah I think I think you started
the 17 and you start him at the starting
line so it's basically a 23 yard dash
for you okay so his for that's
manageable I think that's a good why are
you shaking your head you think that's
he is going
destroy it I know he's trying to save me
here he's trying to save me
great to see you drew thanks for coming
here man you too thanks for coming
really really really appreciate it go
check out Biofreeze calm and check out
what makes drew brees so good in part
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience